in The Not So Wilds of Delaware a very
distant Peak at the basement HQ of Joe
Biden
he's often avoided the spotlight
citing safety
a local theater his occasional stage
but not much of an audience here it's
like geriatric abuse at this point it's
like you're putting an old man out into
like
The public's eye and he obviously can't
handle it I'm a vote for him still but
like he still needs to like get out
there so other people can like know what
he's doing
he needs to win big with black and
Latino voters in urban centers like
Philadelphia
Albert believes he will
are you confident that young black and
Latino voters are going to turn out
provide them when they didn't for
Clinton yes the only people that are
having the one person that voted for
Trump in the handful of people that I
know of the top of my head that vote in
was a white person do you think
of big numbers that he needs I think he
will get the big numbers that he needs
because I think a lot of people thinking
what I'm thinking if he gets elected
president there's not gonna be no talk
about building a wall right after the
first year
[Applause]
today Biden had the benefits of Barack
Obama in town to appeal directly to
black male voters to put aside their
frustrations and vote
it makes things better
you are more likely to have
Representatives like the congressman or
the senator who are going to
look out for you who understand who you
are your voice through them will be
heard
in the corridors of power
in a country Riven with racial division
they are ambitiously hoping for the kind
of historic turnout he generated in
2008. Obama remains among the most
popular figures in American politics and
his high approval ratings are not lost
on Donald Trump who's made dismantling
his legacy a Cornerstone of his own
presidency
away from the cities in white Suburbia
Biden's got to build back confidence
places like swingy Bucks County in other
more heavily Republican suburbs he
doesn't have to win but he's got to
seriously close the gap with Donald
Trump
Karen and Beverly are canvases that know
the challenges
what does Joe Biden need to do here to
be absolutely certain of Victory he has
to get it clearly across that he's
Centrist that he's moderate
uh to to quell the fears of the of
people who are undecided that they're
not going to be voting for socialism I
think as tax policy scares
you know big corporations but for the
lower income man I think and woman
you know 400 000 your taxes wouldn't
change at all if you make less than 400
000 that's pretty much everybody
puppets or protector the polls have him
framed for Success leading by double
digits
Sky News Pennsylvania